他打破我第一个信念是我可以对个股进行估值。
我觉得我对这个世界上所有的公司的认知程度我都没有可能超过我对美团的认知。
但我依然没有办法通过投资美股团赚钱。
我有什么样的理由认为我可以投资别的个股赚钱。
第二个是从15年到21年整个的投资经历美股08年那一次大崩盘到今天，
他其实是没有这种血绷级别的崩盘过的。
所以你只要遇到回调，你就是熬，熬个最多半年，他又回到原来的位置了。
但是中概股那次就不一样，你在406下去了，你在熬熬多少年他到现在也没到406，对不对。
所以我就觉得我当时这样子的一个投资方式是不OK的。
各位听友大家好，欢迎收听雪球出品的后雪长播。
这是一档和投资相关又不止于投资的节目，我是主持人期。
我们父母那一辈女性55岁退休男性60岁退休，这是一个很正常的规律。
大多数人都是这样认定和规划自己的人生的，但现在明显发生了一些变化。
越来越多的人开始思考我是不是能在50岁之前甚至40岁之前退休。
你说是因为市场环境变了生活方式选择多了，
甚至是被这类鼓吹提前退休的自媒体博主，天天PUA多了，可能都对。
但不可否认的是这件事确实摆在了我们的面前，让我们开始思考是不是真的有这种可能性。
国外传来了一个词叫Fire Financial Independence Retire Early，财务自由提前退休。
其实这个话题我们在两年前也聊过，大家感兴趣的话可以回听那一期的嘉宾，
血球球友Poly对Fire生活的不同注解。
Fire这个词听起来很美啊，但真正走到那一步的人往往不仅仅是因为想通了，
而是被推到了某个临界点，最明显的就是你过了35岁的大线之后，逐渐发现你干不动了。
我们今天的球友嘉宾萌萌就是这样，他走过了百度协成美团，将近15年的互联网黄金时代。
在美团提了好几次辞职都被留了下来，直到第四次，他的身体终于最终替他做了决定。
但他能真正放手靠的不只是勇气，还有一套用真心白银换来的投资体系。
他也曾经历过中概股暴跌，账面最高挥赦600多万，他没有消逞，
而是把这笔学费交完之后重新搭起了自己的资产配置框架，让投资收益彻底成为了自己不上班的底气。
发言之后的生活到底是怎么样的呢？
35岁焦虑大厂内耗提前退休，到底要考虑准备哪些事？
这些问题今天萌萌都将会给我们一个很真实的答案。
我其实经历了好几个阶段，我现在是从做个股，
个股就是美股？
中概,
但也是美股了？
最早我做过一点点A股，那个时候我大学，
然后到2015年的时候，那时候因为在互联网，
在协成公司会发我那个期权了，
当时的期权他还是钱是发到境外的股票账户的，
你是可以把这股转到你自己的美股账户里，
包括当时同事在做这种美股的也比较多，
所以就开始搞美股。
在协成待了几年？
纯协成本部的话是两年，
但是因为我前面有一段那个创业公司，
其实它是协成旗下的权资子公司，
那个大概还有个大半年的，
加产在协成体系是三年左右吧？
那个是在几几年的？
一二到一五。
等于你是就三家是吧？
百度协成没判？
可以这样说，
但协成当中有一段跟老板出去创业的经历。
百度在做啥？
当时做国际化，
就是我为什么会尽百度，
是因为我出高中时候是一个特别二次元的人，
高中自学了日语，
大学却日本交换了一年，
大三回来就要找实习，
投了好多公司没有理我的，
然后百度因为他就想要一个会日语的人，
去做产品的实习，
我就去了百度，
就完全不打不撞，
那时候对啥是互联网，
啥是产品经理，
没有任何的概念。
啥是互联网都不知道，
那啥时候呢？
09年,
那时候甚至你知道我夸张到什么程度，
就是有很多公司来学校里面会做那种，
就是校招的宣讲嘛，
当时来一家公司叫迅雷，
那个时候有一阵子大家特别讨厌腾讯，
我不知道你是不是，
我因为这公司名里面有一个叫迅的，
我都不愿意去听，
就真的对这互联网没有任何概念，
到百度也算是一个误答误状，
非常误答误状，
然后干了三年，
对，就是加上实习三年，
因为09年开始我是实习了一年，
那你是上海人对吧，
我是上海人，
所以就是那是第一次去北京，
是这样，
他的国际化有一部分团队在上海，
然后到我毕业那个口，
突然说，
要把所有的国际化团队收回北京，
我又是一个很愿意下跑的人，
然后我也很喜欢北京，
因为我为什么喜欢北京，
是以前很喜欢一部电影叫《霸王别机》，
这个喜欢北京的理由，
特别奇怪，
对，然后我就很想去北京生活一段时间，
就正好公司给了我这机会，
那就去嘛，
然后在北京待了一年之后，
当时是深圳政府给那个百度在深圳。
批了一块地，
百度要在那边造一个百度大楼，
因为百度在深圳的业务其实一直就没做起来，
所以那个楼虽然造了，
其实很大一部分它是出租给别人的，
所以认知应该不是很强烈，
但是百度总要派一些团队在那边嘛，
当时想着因为深圳比较强的是腾讯那时候在那边，
腾讯其实他们是做，
那个时候我们认为是PC端的软件为主，
QQ是个PC端的软件嘛，
所以就想要把一些软件相关的业务派过去，
当时是我在做国际化的输入法，
日本的输入法，
然后就把我们一个小团队排过去了，
那就也算是产品经理了，
对对对，但那个时候的产品经理就是不像这几年那么细分，
就是后来整个公司比如说你有前端，后端，
产品运营交互视觉，
这些岗嘛，
07-10我理解应该还没有进入移动互联网的，
正在转的一个过程中，
所以你不只是做PC同时还要做移动互联网，
那个时候就是我产品运营，
数据交互的活都是产品感，
那时候公众还没有拉那么开，
那你需要跑到日本一线去做一些调研嘛，
用户的需求啊，
会做，也会做，
百度当时还是做国际化的时候是很舍得花钱的，
他在日本那个楼租在六本木Hills，
相当于上海的上海中心这个地位的楼，
一开始租了好像半层，
然后越缩越小，
你在日本待了多久？
一年也就出差个两三次吧，
去那干嘛呢，真的要做一线的用户调研吗？
会做一线的用户调研，
用户样本来到公司，
当然你可能就直接会日语了，
或者其他人通过翻译你要一对一的面谈这种方式吗？
对，其实就是整个用研的那一套东西，
在美国已经发展很完善了，
那个时候百度也愿意在这上面投，
他就有那个有装眼动仪，
看到一个用户他视线在打字的过程中，
他在哪里有卡顿，
然后观察他的整个国际界，
我会给他一个任务list，
他在这个操作完了之后呢，
我再跟他聊，
他刚刚打字的过程中，
你在什么什么是遇到了什么什么样的问题，
或者你平时有没有使用什么样的进品，
跟我们的感受对比是什么样的？
那这搜索还有啥进品，
听起来那个时代除了Google就是雅虎，
我们当时主要做日语的书法，
所以三年时间，
百度那个业务在日本表现得怎么样呢？
百度是这样，就是百度移动多样的书法，
它后来因为是收购了一个公司，
反而是好像国际化，
后来唯一存活下来的一条线，
买的那个公司叫Smaggy，
后来百度在日本的这个产品，
整体就改名叫Smaggy了，
它现在都还活着，
但是书法这产品呢，
即使你在国内就知道，
它是一个挺难变现的一个产品，
所以就你要说做多大也肯定没有，
但活着呢现在也还活着，
当时其实百度，
它花了很大的精力做国际化，
东南亚呀，然后日本，
日韩都有投入，
先做的肯定是搜索那些嘛，
这些全部都是折集尘沙了，
就留下一个日文书法还在那。
你当时在北京待了一年？
对，在北京待了一年，
就被雕去深圳了，
在深圳也待了一年。
那你这北上全待了，
最长的肯定是上海嘛，
那北京和深圳，
你觉得这两个城市工作下来，
有什么感受不同？
我觉得首先工作环境上来说，
北京当时在百度工作的感觉，
我仿佛没有离开我的大学，
好像跟我当时在大学的那个，
就是大家的年龄层次是完全一样的。
就是多很年轻？
都很年轻，
就是我大学比如说研究生，
见到的同学也就是二十四五岁，
但我本科毕业，
然后在百度大厦也就是研究生刚毕业，
或者本科刚毕业就在那儿工作。
零七年左右是吧？
零九一零年，
然后几乎见不到北京人，
百度工作一年，
可能认识比如说一两百个同事，
北京人就一个，
两个。
多元化还是可以的？
所以大家都是外地到那边了之后，
就是在那也没有家人，
在公司和在家是一样的，
甚至我租房子都是跟我同事一起租的，
还是这些人，
我好像没有一种特别的。
到点下班我就要回家的感觉。
明白,
也是年轻吗？
对,
是的,
而且周围所有的同事都是这样的感觉，
而且百度那个时候呢，
确实也是因为搜索比较赚钱，
公司的整个办公环境做的也特别好，
它有一个就是，
大概三五层米高的，
我们当时叫Loft，
然后里面就是绿植，
搞得像个热带雨林一样的，
在那边可以一圈一圈的开小会也行，
我那时候还有一点想法想去美国，
读研,
我周末都会在那去自习，
非常好的一个感受啊，
深圳怎么样？
北京我刚刚讲完，
它是职场嘛，
但是北京这个城市呢，
我从夏儿齐，
到我比如说想完的话，
我可能会想要去，
三里屯，
或者想去那个前后海那边，
太远了，
就是它是完全割裂开的，
两个地方的感觉，
深圳在这一点上就更好，
主要在哪个区？
南山,
我玩的地方，
生活的地方，
工作的地方，
他们全部都在一起，
我每天早上起床，
我有时候六、七点起床，
先去北面，
就是我们家过马路，
就是深圳大学，
在里面可能跑两圈，
去我公司楼下星巴哥吃个早饭，
然后上楼工作，
就是这些全部都在步行范围内，
特别爽，
周末可能就，
我们南山去蛇口园很近嘛，
去蛇口做个船去香港，
买买买，
这两城我都挺喜欢，
但如果你说，
但城市来说，
我是更喜欢深圳的，
在上海深圳北京里面，
我深圳都可能是最喜欢深圳的，
上海都不能拍的一，
上海就是跟深圳有不一样的地方，
拍出你自己家的这块儿的因素，
甚至还有什么父母，
咱把这块儿先刨来，
上海是那种有些街道，
你周边是一两百年的那种老洋房，
对,
它是有这种，
然后无铜树，
然后秋天你骑个自行车，
是这种很有韵味的感觉，
深圳的好呢，
它是那种，尤其冬天，
你在上海就已经很冷很冷了，
你到那边还是绿植，
所以北京这个深圳，
确实是你百度的第一段嘛，
当时就怎么就决定，
我上,
换一家公司，
或者回到上海，
因为我现在老公，
结果我当时男朋友，
我俩是大学就在一起了，
但我们俩不是一个大学，
它是我大学室友的，
小学初中高中同学，
然后我们是大四，
我从日本回来，
我们俩开始谈，
那个时候我差不多25岁嘛，
在深圳，
我妈就一直催我回来，
她在上海？
她在一个国际，
她现在也还在这个国际，
然后我妈就不想我一直在外面飘，
她觉得我在外面飘，
我就不想回上海了，
当时就开始看一些，
上海这边的工作机会，
没有想到就是一看就拿到了offer，
因为那时候找工作真的是太容易了，
就是随便一看，
就是一看就是一个offer，
一看就是一个offer，
为啥呢？就是百度的经历给你的？
因为那个时候就是互联网增长最快的时候，
12年了,
然后产品经历的需求缺口非常大，
百度那个时候其实是她最顶衬的时候，
因为刚进一栋互联网，
其实她的那个流量衰退还没有，
感觉就跟现在的AR是她，
对对对，
是的,
那个时候我觉得整个世界，
就是做互联网的人，
都还是草台班子，
都不知道怎么做，
虽然在百度也很草台班子，
已经属于这个行业里面，
相对好像懂一点的人了，
明白吗？
最后去了协城，
不是,
当时去了铝平网，
铝平网它是协城旗下的这家全资子公司，
创立的背景呢，
它是想做一个旅游社区，
因为那个时候，
其实穷游和马蜂窝的势头很好，
然后国外像那个trip advisor，
在pce的时候，
它也是一家很赚钱的公司，
那个时候有一度，
它是单人的市值最高的公司，
整个美国，
就是协城看到了这个机会了之后，
它就想做一个trip advisor，
国内它的进品，
其实就是穷游和马蜂窝，
这些公司最后为什么黄了呢？
我觉得两方面原因，
第一个是说到移动互联网时代，
首先trip advisor,。
自己也没有活得那么好，
大家没有那么习惯，
再从一个第三方看一个品价，
ranking,。
再到一个地方去做预定这个行为了，
第二个点是，
其实国内的，
我觉得OTA自己的，
酒店的评分体系，
做的还是可以的，
协生自己做的还是可以的，
你直接参考那个评分就行了，
第三方网站的价值没有那么高，
然后之后就被协城给收回去了？
对，当中我短暂创业了几个月吧，
因为那时候我们的老板，
因为他自己的背景是，
他在美国工作了很多年回来的，
他是在美国四大工作了很多年，
他回来就是不想在大公司干了，
他就想自己创业，
所以他不想回去，
但是那个时候，
梁建章他觉得，
整个移动互联网的量潮起来了，
你那么多小蘑菇公司，
就是对协城集团是没有价值的，
然后就把这个收回去，
我当时候反正，
我觉得年轻也没有特别大的判断力吧，
就跟着他去创业了一段时间，
后来因为两个老板，
他们意见不是很统一，
这个公司就黄了，
因为协城当时那个驴平王，
本身是六七十个人，
出去创业是十几个人，
然后有很多原来的统治，
他也就是去了协城的那个，
当时叫攻略社区部门，
我就让我前同事帮我投了一下检历，
然后就去了攻略社区当产品，
在协城大概两年多。
那段时间的协城，
和我们现在认识的协城有什么不一样吗？
我觉得协城本身也许没有那么大的差异，
但是外界对他的感受的差异挺不一样的，
因为我觉得那个时候，
整个就是一栋互联网是增长最快的时候，
但协城其实它已经是一家十几年的老公司了，
并且它一直不是那种。
特别拼命的那种劲的公司，
从一开始它就是觉得你任何的一个员工，
它是有生活和有工作的公司，
但当我自己在一个特别高的增长的预期，
这个行业的员工在特别高增长的预期的时候，
就会觉得这样慢的公司，
它是有很多问题的，
觉得它特别的国旗份，
它八年以上的老员工特别多，
那是我当时对它的一个感觉，
现在就完全不一样了，
因为我觉得整个行业的增长速度慢下来了之后，
大家反而都是回归到。
想要一种生活和工作的平衡里面，
觉得这个公司真香，
然后它做的一些work for a home也好，
然后包括一些它对生育的激励也好，
就是觉得它是一个很有社会责任感的公司。
当然这个肯定是和梁电章本人有关系的，
更重视这个work-life balance,。
你觉得更多是因为老板是上海人，
还是因为他在美国工作过，
或者生活过，
所以他有这样的一些背景？
可能都有，不光是协成，
后来其实是在美团点评工作了接近10年的时间，
我进去的那时候，那家公司还叫大众点评，
是我进去几个月之后才在河北，
那是上海公司，
对，大众点评也是一下很典型的上海老板做的公司，
张涛嘛，他也是美国背景回来，
对，就是是上海背景，还是美国背景，
对，我觉得可能都有。
从另外一个角度来说，
百度连红是美国背景，
虽然他不是上海人，
你要这样说，
黄欣也在美国留学过，
那完全不一样的风格。
这个倒是，这个倒是，
我们先把协成说完，
我们从最近几年吧，
尤其是最近几个月，
我们看到两两张还是比较平凡的接受一些媒体的采访，
公众更多的知道了一些协成现在的一些管理和制度，
然后包括你刚才提到的work from home，
居家办公这些事，
至少在节目里的表态是，
似乎它是中国非常少去推行这件事的，
是不是你压根没赶上这个过程？
是的，我是15年就走了，
协成应该是当中它又经历了和先是和美团的战争，
当时因为美团的旧旅发展也非常的快速。
也是因为这个你去了美团是吧？
不是，我在那之前我就去了，
我当时去的原因就是我刚讲的，
我嫌弃协成自己发展太慢的那种感觉。
人生阶段不一样，
你要的东西是不是就不一样，
现在来看觉得看到了协成的好，
但是在更年轻的时候还是想拼一下？
是，但是我不会去后悔我当时选择离开美团，
因为如果我还在协成，
我是不可能在我这个年纪达到现在的财富水平的。
在美团一直是做这种和点评相关的业务吗？
因为一开始是大众点评是独立公司，
然后它后来叫点评平台。
哦，等于其实你一开始去到大众点评？
对，6月去的到10月国庆休假回来，
世界变天了，就是这种感觉。
其实那时候不叫被收了，
因为那个时候合并它是叫美团点评，
讲的是双总部，双CEO联系制，
它是逐渐才那个就是张涛也退了呀，
老点评的高管都走了呀，
然后逐渐在变成美团。
我在点评平台，
加上大众点评一共三年的时间，
到18年,
然后去了叫到店综合，
就是偏做到店的非餐饮业务的一个部门，
呆了可能有四五年的时间吧，
一直呆到二三年，
然后回点评又呆了一年，
一直到二四年底选择离开。
那肯定一开始你想的简单了，
事实证明所有的这种业务，
最后都会被所谓的集团化，
或者融入化的，
摩拜单车也是这样，
可能其他的业务也都是类似的命运。
还不太一样，
比如摩拜单车，
像这些业务它收购的时候，
它就说的很明白叫收购，
美团点评当时叫换股，
叫法就不一样，
但是在点评的内部，
其实我们都有一种恐惧的心理，
它其实是一次吞噬，
然后很担心公司还是不是要这个APP，
所以其实我在点评的从合并后，
直到我离开一八年的那段时间，
我觉得其实这个业务的人，
它是有很大的一种存在焦虑的。
至少截止到一八年，
你那个截点发现还行，是吧？
到一八年到还没有还行，
到24年我因为又回去了一次嘛，
那个时候大家真的有一种就是，
公司这么多年也没把我们干掉，
真的是看不掉的那个感觉。
或者说就是它融入的不够狠，
其实融入的也挺狠的了，
完全就是美团的一个概念了嘛。
在公司层面是这样，
但是在产品层面，
我觉得它不是一个以人的意志为转移的，
因为点评它本身，
最早它立身只本是一个评价平台，
它评价平台的这一套机制呢，
它还是独立的在绕，
但是你一个评价平台要怎么变现，
它其实就到业务层嘛，
比如说餐饮业务你要接团购，
这些业务层其实是完全的融合了。
你当时在美团具体做什么呢？
哪一块的产品经历？
在点评的阶段我其实负责过好几块，
做过就是一个我们叫基础产品，
就是比如说你点评App，
比如说首页，
然后我们叫我的Tab，
然后我的里面的所有的什么收藏要订单，
这个是我负责过的一段，
我们叫基础，
你可以认为就是整个App的一个底层框架的东西，
有一段我负责美食产品，
因为它又和就是刚讲到的业务端，
它是两块，
我负责的就是用户在点评上找餐厅的体验，
当时就是15-18年比较投入众作的一个事情就是推荐菜，
推荐菜最早呢，
它是一个很简单的产品，
它整个的体验大概就是你可以去创建一个菜，
你也可以传途，
然后你点那个菜品名进去就是好多这个菜的图片，
它有一个推荐数，
然后我们逐渐把这个体系更丰富，
包括它的数据化更丰富，
做这个事情。
之后到了18年就离开了？
对，当时其实是因为这样，
我有一个就是做了很长时间的老板，
在协产他就是我老板，
我当时来点评的很大一部分原因，
也是因为他来了点评，
他自己在17年其实去了到店综合，
我到18年就也去了到店综合，
18年不是说离开了美团？
没有离开美团，
就是在到店综合，
但还在美团体系内，
我们就管它叫偏业务的一块东西，
然后就一直在到店这个业务线去干，
干到了啥时候？
23年底,
然后又回点评待了一年，
中间是没有间断的，
就是一直在美团的大的体系下面，
然后最终24年退休了，
这个里面肯定就有几个，
听我们比较好奇一会儿感兴趣的点，
什么是你24年决定退休的决定性因素？
我觉得最核心的因素，
是因为做互联网产品这件事情，
不再让我觉得快乐了，
我觉得我自己还是一个比较兴趣驱动的人，
包括最早因为学日语，
去了做了百多日文的产品也好，
去做旅行相关的，
做美食相关的，
其实都是我自己感兴趣的东西，
包括做产品经理，
我觉得它是一份，
能够让我不断接触新领域的东西，
24年的那个阶段，
我会觉得我所接触的东西，
有一点在不断重复了，
而且整个公司的增长变慢了之后，
它就会有很多问题会暴露出来，
比如说团队的氛围会比较为上，
很难去支撑每一个人自己的成长的诉求，
不光是我自己，
我带一个二十几人的团队，
我觉得做管理者当中，
很大的乐趣是，
你要看着每一个人，
他自己发展的溯源也要得到满足，
我觉得我也满足不了他们，
就是我自己做这个事不快乐，
他们做这个事也不快乐，
这个事让我很内耗，
我本身有一个疾病叫，
乔本是假装腺炎，
这个疾病它会有一个特点，
脑子里面想很多事，
但是好像没力气去做，
二十四年底的时候，
我觉得屈体化比较严重了，
我有一天，
早上做了一个稍微有点强度的瑜伽，
中午去公园快走了一圈，
然后到晚上到凌晨三点都睡不着觉，
就是因为它这个病还有一个，
就是你运动了一兴奋，
人就是平静不下来，
它叫圣上腺疲劳，
反正就是确实去做了检查，
然后医生告诉你，
这有一个明确的一个病的名字，
对对对，
然后那天就睡不着觉，
而且我翻身都翻不动，
我翻身都觉得特别累，
然后我当时就觉得不行，
第二天早上就给我老板，
发那个微信说我这班上不了，
这么直接吗？
对，因为当然这个不是，
就是一下子的，
因为在那之前，
我在美团已经提了三次辞职了，
那次也是因为这个病的原因吗？
还是别的？
不是，就是因为我觉得在这不开心，
他当时就说，
你要不等一等，
那个时候是二十四年底嘛，
他说你要不然等年中奖发完了，
再看一看，
这老板真好，
对，整个会员网变化也特别多嘛，
他说你看，
公司会不会再有些调整啊，
类似这种感觉，
我当时说也行，
到那天我就觉得我等不下去了，
在之前是我跟不同的另外两人老板，
我都提过离职，
那那个时候是啥原因呢？
第一次是因为我二一年生完了娃，
二二年的十月份，
就是我的不如嫁结束之后，
我选择去了一个新的部门，
带更大的团队，
就是比如说我原来是一个一级管理者，
我去了新部门，
我是一个二级管理者，
管理宽缚一下子宽了很多，
正好在那个时间点上是美团，
每一年十月份要写OP，
Operation Plan,。
每一年写OP就是。
大一层皮的那种感觉，
就是通宵特别多，
加班特别多，
因为原来跟小孩，
就是我每天六点下班，
我有很多时间见他，
突然就是到了我每天要加班，
我每天都见不到他，
我就是觉得这不是我想要的生活，
然后我就跟我老板说我不想，
在这儿了，
我比较擅长的，
就是我之前所有的经历，
我做的都是C端产品，
然后我老板他很缺一个，
就是做C端产品的产品经理Leader，
所以他还是很希望当时留下来，
因为做OP他有每个人负责的part，
他说就是跟你没关系的那些，
你可以比如说线上旁听，
不用每一天都陪我们开会开到那么晚，
因为这个调整我后来也就留下来了，
第二次是跟身体原因有关系，
当时是疫情放开之后，
二阳了，得肺炎了，
一直低烧不断，
就是37度5，
37度6那种，
在家里面修了一个月的并价，
但是你这个就是一个萝卜一个坑，
就是该开的会还要开嘛，
那个阶段是美团在跟抖音打仗，
所以整个公司他的目标是做交易导向的，
但是我当时所在的那个部门，
年度的KPI都是以采收为目标的，
他就造成了我老板他的部下，
我们的目标是不一致的，
我负责的我是要做交易的，
但我们的销售负责人他是要做采收的，
有一次开会针对一些问题，
就吵得特别严重，
我当时就是觉得我在这发点烧火，
何必呢，
然后我又不想干了，
我说我要辞职，
但是我也知道底点不能说走就走嘛，
那你这坑怎么办呢，
然后我就说那你们去市场上找吧，
你找到了人我再走，
正好就是我在等他们找的那个过程中，
我之前就合作了很多年的那个老板，
他之前是因为心肯休息了一段时间，
这说的好废话呀，
他回来了，
然后公司就把他安排到点评，
然后他说要不你来点评吧，
就去点评，又工作了一年，
整个听下来，
其实如果大家有兴趣的话，
可以听我们之前的某一期节目，
我们也有一个对唐嘉宾叫，
我们简称他叫莫姐，
也是一个就像你一样的，
就是已经把自己fire掉的一个女性，
原来是我的同事，
但是呢在之前其实他在阿里，
一个十年的阿里人，
刚才你说的这些就是在那期节目里，
丽丽在目啊，
就几乎都是一样的原因，
要不然有工作的压力，
有自己的身体状况，
包括越来越不满意自己的工作状态，
也是大厂的到了一定的平静之后，
觉得无论是自己缺乏发展，
还是业务缺乏发展，
然后在团队当中开始，
从一个普增长的一个状态，
到开始互抢资源，
互私从而产生了一些心理焦虑，
我在想是不是这个大厂普遍都有这样的焦虑，
你觉得多吗？
我觉得多呀，
大家都在这儿撑着，
应该说增长可以掩盖一切问题，
就是前几年因为增长的比较好，
可能存在一些问题，
大家不那么在意，
不管自己的成长也好，
你的钱也在涨也好，
整个公司都在涨，
但是当增长放缓的时候，
一切问题就暴露了出来，
你经历过那个所谓的35岁焦虑吗，
总监或者中层管理员到35被大量干掉的这种？
可能再待两年就可以容性的说到一个大礼包，
但是在他干掉我之前，
我就选择了自己干掉自己，
所以就没来得及，
但是我周边有人有，
我觉得这个事情本质上是这样子的，
就是一个人，
他的工作能力，
包括他的工作意愿，
并不会因为三十五岁而产生一个质变，
但是当外界他给了这个东西之后，
所有的大厂都要做年轻化，
他会给予一些人，
把人换成自己人的空间，
我周围有朋友是技术的leader，
敬点名我就跟他一起合作，
我觉得他特别优秀，
然后后来他来了新的老板，
他在公司时间太长为有，
就是让他自己出去看机会了，
但他后面也找到了机会。
这个理由，
我相信他是可能是一个现实存在的一类理由，
就是说整个大厂的焦虑下，
以互联网公司为代表，
无论是从你的实际的工作经历，
这个经历是指你的energy，
这个经历可能你的自己的心愁，
本身到三十五岁也已经到了一定的量了，
如果我能换一比你年轻十岁，
又比你便一半的人就为什么不呢？
从整个经济的收缩到规模的这种平静之下，
所产生的这种年轻化的这种替化，
我都觉得并不是说真觉得你不行，
可能完全是从精明减证，
节约成本的角度来去看这件事情。
我觉得是这样，
就是首先到了三十五岁之后，
如果你再把自己放到市场上，
你想要去换一个工作，
机会一定是大量减少的。
是的。
我自己没这个经验，
但我也有朋友，
跟我是同龄的，
他非常清晰的感觉到，
就是三十五岁前后他去抛出减力，
收到的回应是完全数量级的那个差异。
如果你待在一家公司，
原来技校也在中等水平以上，
没有很大的风险，
但是我觉得AI这一波来了之后，
又完全不一样了。
尤其是在一些竞争环境的公司，
他的去降本的那个动力会非常强，
那这个时候即使是中等技校的，
如果是一个三十五岁以上的人，
我觉得他的风险会增大很多。
所以你也比较庆幸，
你没赶上AI那一波是吧？
没有啊，我挺失望的，
我要是赶上了，
我不能多一个大礼包吗？
你觉得你是会多一个大礼包，
而不是说，
哎，你看又有新的增量出来，
那我刚才在干净。
我是这样想的，
一个人，
比如说用AI的说法，
你的算力其实是有限的，对吧？
如果我现在在一家公司，
我的注意力必须放在公司关注的事情上，
那当然。
对，比如说公司现在让我搞足了，
我其实对这好像没那么大兴趣，
作为个人，
但是我得把我的所有的精力都投入在上面，
但如果我现在是一个独立的个人了，
我喜欢心理学，
我就研究我的心理学，
我可以用AI研究我的心理学，
独立个人也可以做你自己爱干的事情。
所以你觉得你最后在2024年放弃，
还是一个比较不错的工作的时候，
这不是一个处心积虑的过程吗？
其实还是有点压死落头的最后一根稻草这种感觉。
感觉你这两词用的都没问题啊，
是一个处心积虑的过程。
处心积虑我的意思是，
早就想好了我最终离职，
只是我在做那个准备。
是的，我确实是的。
你试试吗？
但是我听起来感觉是，
虽然是提了很多次，
但是前几次你毕竟又都回来了吗？
对。
所以那这一次到底是什么，
让你真的确定说我就要走出去了？
身体吧，
而且确实就是工作给我的这种，
不管是成就感啊，
愉悦的感觉，逐年的在下降。
就是你正向的收益越来越少，
但是负面的东西在逐步叠加，
不管是说我这种不自由的感觉，
身体的不适感啊。
我可能必须得问那做这个决定前后吧，
你的家里人怎么看？
说实话，我这个想法提了有两三年嘛。
最开始的时候，
比如说我父母是比较反对的，
我老公他是比较焦虑的，
因为这个事情，
因为我之前在我们家收入也是一个大头，
因为他们也看着我，
其实身体状况是越来越不好，
并且我一度需要给工作投入的时间是非常高的，
所以他们也逐渐能够理解，
我的这个选择。
因为我写我的公众号，
然后里面写我怎么想这个不工作这个事，
然后写我怎么考虑投资这个事，
我觉得也是跟他们沟通的一种方式吧。
所以最终你还是得到了家人的理解的？
是的。
叫得到理解还是得到支持？
我觉得我父母是理解，
我老公是支持。
老公也是后来支持，
是吧？一开始还是非常紧张的？
对对对。
他这个紧张是怎么缓解呢？
除了比如说他爱你，
他联系你的身体这件事之外？
这个事其实我俩是一样的，
当真的辞职这个事发生了之后，
发现一天没他下来，
那个紧张自己就没有了，
我自己也是，
我自己就是在辞职前，
我那时候有一个表，
就是每一年的算我们家那个投资收益率是多少，
然后支出是多少，
然后最后我们家会不会破产，
然后没事就在那儿算，
然后一天可能要算十几遍，
这是我焦虑的体现，
现在我就不会去拿那个表没事老算了，
因为辞职了天也没他下来，
那个焦虑就自己消失不见了。
你最早是什么时候开始接触投资的吧？
大学的时候，
我们学校开了一门课，
就是教那个怎么炒股的。
零几年的事儿了，是吧？
零六零七年的事儿，
教你怎么看K线图那种，
甚至老师在课上还给我推了两只股票，
就是现在看了好像不可思议的事情是不是，
然后我就买了一些股票，
结果赶上我忘了是08-09年。
A股吗?
A股啊，08-09年就开始大跌，
一直跌了两三年，
包括我09年开始实习，
10年开始正式工作了之后，
工资长得是很快的呀，
那个股票老在那每个月阴跌，
那我肯定没有什么动力再去持续关注他了，
不管他了。
也没赎回？
好像是赎回了吧，
因为也不多钱，
但同时一个发生的事情，
10年到15年之间加入互联网，
当时周围全部都是这样的声音，
比如说在百度是这样的，
就是某一次他们业绩特别好，
李洋红让所有人选，
你们是要年终奖家一千块钱，
还是多给你们一千百度股票，
所有人选了一千块钱。
如果当时他们选了百度股票，
他们现在都财务自由了，
全部都是这样的故事，
然后包括我后面到点评的，
我的一个老板，
他也是在腾讯发的股票，
然后发了，
马上卖了，
在深圳买一套房，
当时没卖的话，
他的下属的下属都财务自由了，
类似于这种故事。
持续被奖了很多年了？
是的,
就会觉得中概股的股票的投资，
是一个让人很容易接近财务自由的事。
从10年进百度的那个时候，
就已经听到这样的故事了。
就已经听到这样的故事了，
但当时我还没有去自己去做这个投资。
你进去的时候有没有给到汽权？
没有，我进去一个P2，
到我去协成13年的时候，
然后那个时候我进去的等级是4C，
那个时候是4C，
它转5A的时候，
到你实习结束，
它会给你重新定级，
你定级到了5A以上，
就是现场发股票。
这个非常有意思，
就是给你签你要7权，
还是你要限制性股权，
ICU,
我要了ICU，
就是限制性股权。
它这个限制是体现在哪？
就是分四次卖，
它其实就是每一年解冻25%，
比如说给你价值50万的，
你每年可以解冻12.5万，
类似于这种感觉，
这个是13年嘛，
协成当时发的这个股票，
它是在境外的股票账户，
你可以直接把它转到你自己的，
我当时好像还用的是first trade，
那个真的是太难用了，
一个选手软件，对，
后来因为你相当于有股票在那里面，
你就可以自己进行操作了嘛，
就可以买别的了，是吧？
对对对，
然后从2015年开始，
更多的花一些精力在这个事情上面，
那就是2015年左右开始，
算是正式的开始炒美股了，
你当时的资金体量是多大？
它是逐步扩大的，
21年那时候中概股崩盘，
我当时盈利最高额是900多万，
回撤了600多万人民币，
就是说你先盈利了900多万人民币，
后来又回撤了600多万，
那可以了，
还是有非常好的，
底部收益的300多万，
对是，还行，
但是这个事儿，
你要这么看它，
就为什么后来我就不做个股了，
就是因为如果你真的选择file，
就是你退休了，
你看着账户老这么回撤，
340%的是一个很痛苦的体验，
因为你当退撤的时候，
你永远不知道它还会不会回来的，
从你刚才说的大概15年左右开始，
然后认真投，
到你刚才说的21年赚了900万，
这不就6年嘛，
这个中间买了些啥？
就有一段时间，
我是美股的头部的，
那个时候叫Fan，
F-A-A-N-G,。
现在好像叫七姐妹，
Fan的这些公司我买，
中概股的公司买，
新能源汽车，
就是理想未来那些，
那个我也赚了一波钱，
也算中概，
只不过不是中概互联的吧？
对对,
当时是因为美团也投了理想，
那个时候我还是非常，
相信美团的判断力的，
2021年的时候，
那时候我看那个，
段永平的理念吧，
当时他提到一个点，
就是跟别人不太一样，
他觉得没有必要为了分散而分散，
比如说他手上有很多的苹果，
他今天如果为了要分散，
就是我必须单个的持股，
只有10%到20%的话，
相当于要卖掉我，
认为特别好的苹果，
我去换一个公司，
但是这个世界上有什么公司，
值得让我用苹果去换呢，
我可能找不到，
当时觉得哎呀，好有道理，
然后包括因为我又在美团，
那时候特别看好美团，
一度我美团的持仓的集中度，
可能到670%，
然后到21年12月份的时候，
中概股见顶了，
那时候美团460，
就一直跌到今天80几，
你是啥时候出的？
我集中出货，
应该是在200多块钱，
可以啊，
也赚了一大票了，
是的,
就是美团他打破了我的两个信念，
我也想问，
就是说股价折扮之后，
实际当时发生了什么事，
让你觉得不再持有它了？
他打破我第一个信念，
是我可以对个股进行估值，
我觉得我对这个世界上，
所有的公司的认知程度，
我都没有可能超过，
我对美团的认知程度，
那这是可以理解的，
但我依然没有办法，
通过投资美股团赚钱，
我有什么样的理由，
认为我可以投资别的个股赚钱，
第二个是，
从15年到21年，
整个的投资经历，
每股08年那一次大崩盘，
到今天它其实是没有，
这种血崩级别的崩盘过的，
所以你只要遇到回调，
你就是熬，
熬个最多半年，
它又回到原来的位置了，
但是中概股那次就不一样，
你在460下去了，
你在熬熬多少年，
它到现在也没到460，对不对？
所以我就觉得，
我当时这样子的一个投资方式，
是不OK的，
所以我就想找一些新的，
怎么做投资的方式，
然后当时最早接触的是，
ETF拯救事件，
它是做那个行业指数和资产配置的一个，
但是它行业指数做的是比较精的嘛，
所以我当时是follow过它的一段策略，
然后包括我自己也投行业指数，
因为我投它的那一段时间，
是大概是22年到23年，
也是A股比较硬跌的一个状态，
它当时的风格，
我认为从资产配置的角度来说，
还是把过多的资产集中在了A股，
而且它也没有集中的一个保护的策略，
所以整个持股体验还是挺差的，
我又在想有没有别的方式，
当时其实有一个策略，
把护身300，中阵500，标普500，
纳斯大克100和债券分成5份，
然后每年做一次再平衡，
这个的10年回报率可能也有在10%左右，
并且它整体的持仓体验，
其实它会比你集中在单一市场要好一些，
所以我后来就是基于这一套策略，
在逐渐迭带了一个更均衡配置的策略，
我有一段时间的策略也差不多是，
跟刚那个比较类似，
但是我基于PE的分位会做一些调整，
PE分位高的时候，
我就少配一些估值，
多拿一些债券，
PE分位低的时候，
我就多拿一些估值，
少拿一些债券，
但是这样的一个策略，
还是想再插一句，
刚才你提到从400多美团的顶峰，
然后200多卖的嘛，
跌了一半了，
美团的发生了什么事，
然后让你觉得说200，
它就必须得都出完了。
因为美团其实它在21年的时候，
在搞叫美团优选的一个业务，
它其实是次日的一个身先的一个模式，
跟拼多多打，
多多叫多多买菜嘛，
那一仗其实是我认为，
肯定是不能算赢，
打平或者输了，
大概是这样的一个状态吧，
美团其实在21年前呢，
它在很多的战场，
它虽然是一个后发，
但是它可以后发之人，
比如说它做电影，
做的猫眼，
比如说它做酒旅，
比如说它做团购，
其实当时跟大容点评打，
它也是后发的，
但是它都是最后做到了。
市场上领先的地位，
美团这个公司跟别的互联网公司，
它有一些非常不同的地方，
没有那么追求你做决策的快，
但追求做决策的质量，
大部分的互联网公司，
比如说百度字节，
这样很典型的，
我们叫A面公司，
信息的传递，
它都是在线上的，
这样的公司，
它是很适合我们叫AB测试，
就是你什么东西，
你上线了，
你真相去试一下吗？
划一部分用户，
先试一下，
对对对，
它的成本很低，
它结论出的很快，
它是这样子的一种认知的方式，
美团不一样，
美团做所有的调整，
你会影响到你的商户，
然后我们内部的节点来说，
比如说你产品经理做了这个决策，
你要有产品运营，
做怎么跟商户协调的方案，
然后它到销售运营，
去制定奖金制度，
销售怎么愿意帮你去推广这个事情，
销售再到商户跟商户的沟通，
然后上线了这个供给之后，
用户看到的感受是什么样的，
比如说你不能是，
我是A用户，
我看到这儿有个会员卡，
你不是，
那你可能要去打12315了，
所以它的整个链条特别长，
以至于就是产品经理做决策的时候，
你必须是一个想清楚的，
我们是要求就是很多事情，
你是想清楚的再干，
所以它有很多自己内部关于。
做决策的这一套方法，
论什么三层四面呀，
一堆的这些东西，
到多多买菜和美团，
优选的这一账来看，
因为它其实很多的决策，
它是发生在当地的，
地面的，
你再靠这样总部驱动的一套，
竞争机制美团就慢了，
所以我觉得是一部分，
打破了我对美团这一套方法论，
它可以在整个商业战场上，
取胜概率的一种信仰，
所以就是到200，
这个信仰就差不多了，
还有一个也不是很理性的决定，
因为老王退了，
我觉得包括我自己也好，
美团当时的一批人，
都是很仰慕老王的，
就是叫王惠文，
这个算是一个，
就是影响你去继续持有它的因素，
你买的时候，
肯定还是一个相对比较低的价格，
就陆陆续续都有，
成本价你还记得吗，
如何成本吧，
这个很难说，
因为我有一些是发的，
我近大众点评的时候，
它给我的成本是5美金一股，
好便宜啊，
30多块人民币，
反正最后肯定是赚的，
是的,
你是什么时候开始，
通过一些比较专业的方式，
进行投资的，
比如你刚才，
已经提到PE等等的一些，
专业词汇了，
你是从股票时代，
比如说我看企业基本面，
我就引入了一些估值方式，
就开始以专业的视角，
看这些个股了吗，
还是说我的专业度是从，
你刚才说的ETF投资开始的，
如果是PE这个程度的话，
我个股时代应该也懂，
但是你要说我做个股的时候，
就很了解对企业如何做估值，
我是没有这个能力的，
我是在21年那个时候，
我刚才讲到我生娃，
之前反正身体一些原因吧，
也休假了一段时间，
我当时看了挺多投资相关的书，
而且因为那个时候，
就是最痛的时候，
正好亏了那么多钱，
未来有一天，
我肯定是要进入这种，
彻底不上班的状态的，
我不能让我的钱在这样，
那有什么办法，
所以那段时间是看了挺多书，
所以当时你决定说，
我要开始尝试，
比如说指数类投资，
就是因为你亏了600万，
是，在那之前，
我有两个朋友，
他是做这种行业指数方式的，
但说实话，
就是当时看不上他们，
觉得收益率太低，
亏了600万就看上了，
对对对，就老实了，
我觉得也不是所有人，
都会像你这么想问题，
可能有一部分玩家，
他亏了600万之后，
他会重新附盘自己的股票思路，
重新去约束自己的股票策略，
是的,
而不是完全转到另外一个投资品来，
是的，我有很多朋友是这样，
所以你怎么没去，
重新的去判断一下，
自己股票的框架是不是有问题，
进而继续的投股票？
因为对我影响比较大的一本书，
是那个大位F史文森，
他写的叫《机构投资的创新之路》，
他其实是负责耶鲁的校园基金，
因为我觉得他面临的问题，
跟我是一模一样的，
就是你有一个资金池，
你不断的要从里面取钱，
所以你必须要控制回撤，
因为当你回撤太大，
然后又遇到取钱的时候，
你对本金是一个不可恢复的伤害，
遇到的问题就是，
我怎么在控制回撤的同时，
要允许大家不断的，
从这个资金池里取钱？
我明白你的意思，
就是这个我问个小细节，
21年亏了600万，
站在那个时间节点上，
因为你是到24年，
才正式的卸联归田的，
但21年其实你还在工作，
当时的这一部分，
最大的那部分，900万的资金，
其实不止900万了，
如果你要算上他本身的这部分，
这部分应该不是你随时需要调用的钱吧，
因为你还有正常的收入，
包括你老公也有正常的上班收入，
对，因为我21年就开始想着我想退休了，
就是想着如果我要退休，
那我遇到的投资的问题是这样一个问题，
我觉得美团这家公司教会我的一点，
就是你做什么事情，
你先看历史上谁遇到过跟你类似的问题，
解的最好的是谁，
然后你就抄他，
你当时看到就是大卫视文字，
我就觉得这个就是我遇到的问题，
我就要抄他，我是这样的一个想法。
OK，最打动或者让你最印象深刻的。
大卫视文森的关键性理念是什么？
我觉得就是资产配置吧，
不要过度集中，
比如说你如果在某一个资产大类，
占到你的比例超过40%，
或者超过30%，
他觉得是不可谓的一个状态，
我今年又迭代了，
这个可以后面再说。
刚才你说的那一套，
已经和你在之前一点点看到的。
段永平的观点，
完全不一样了，
所以你是咋又完成自我洗脑的了，
因为段永平的时候，
你已经觉得这好有道理，
那之后他就又没道理了吗？
面对的问题不一样，
史文森的他这个问题，
就是我刚讲的那个问题，
你有一个资金池，
希望他保持增长，
也要控制他的大富汇撤。
你预演的情况是，
未来可能这个就是你的底仓了，
但是每年你需要从他的盈利里面，
变成你的生活费。
其实实际操作的话，
比如说我预留3到5年的生活费，
别的钱在里面滚，
但我也会控制他的汇撤，
因为我不太确定，
比如说我生活中会不会发生一些事情，
需要我去动到投资的这部分钱。
开始按照史文森的这个理论，
去重新搭自己的资产架构的时候，
大概是怎么搭的呢？
站在21年的那个节点。
其实我是逐渐调整的，
比如说把一些行业指数就清掉了，
我的个股清掉了，
买入一些美股。
一开始做到的是，
A股和美股的指数加上债券这样一个组合，
然后逐渐又加了黄金。
刚才说的A股美股加债券，
三方的配比是怎么样？
漏了橫壳，
橫壳也有。
A港美,
对对对，
你这个债是指美债还是中债？
中债,
美债我也配一点点，
但不多。
A股和美股我是互生三百，
中正五百，
NAS打克标普五百，
然后他们每一个的持仓上限在20%，
基于PE分位会做一些动态调整。
你的那个就是那只和标普基本上，
是用你的美股账户来实现的，是吧？
对。
如果现在投资者刚入居，
你可能只能用QDI的方式来做。
是的。
当然也是可以实现的。
橫壳是持仓上限是10%，
做一个也是PE分位的动态。
总共那边是，
20,
然后,
每一个指数10，
就是变成了40，
40,
就债券总共20。
因为它是动态的吗？
对。
所以有可能今天，
如果那只它10年的PE在80%，
其实我只配了4%的那只，
那我剩下的16%，
我就全C到了债券。
就完全不会受，
现在整体宏观经济的，
热度情绪的一些影响，
反正你完全遵循这个纪律。
有一段时间是这样，
到去年底，
今年初的时候，
我又觉得这一套东西，
对，有一些问题，
它的问题是在于，
牛市的行情中，
你会失掉很多的手艺。
对。
比如说，
那只,
它能够在PE分位80以上，
躺着35年，
当中可能很偶尔下来一下，
马上又上去了。
是。
你如果完全遵照这套纪律的话，
你会造成，
在牛市当中，
大部分的手艺你是吃不到的。
其实去年关税之后，
就已经出现这个现象了。
是。
所以我基本上是，
去年4月，
我到7、8、9月，
我的收益是很好的，
到9月之后，
我可能就一直是持平了，
因为我的持仓其实是太低了，
开始着急了。
我就在想，
有没有办法解决这个问题，
正好今年又，
听到了一套新的理论。
今年听到的新理论是什么？
就是有一本书叫，
避风港，
它是那个，
塔勒布的那个，
合伙人写的，
讲的就是，
跟塔勒布的，
肥尾效应是，
类似的理论。
它大概的意思，
就是说，
它不是通过资产配置，
避免这种大幅回彻，
它的方法是，
资产是满仓的配，
比如说，
它是97%的权益，
加3%的保险，
所谓的保险，
其实就是，
买7权。
对冲策略了？
对对对，
所以我现在，
在尝试这一套思路。
就是按照这个配比吗？
挺接近的，
但是没有到这个程度，
我现在是这样，
这个ICM的保证金，
是占20%,
但如果看到，
它整个的一个价值，
比如说一手ICM，
我假如说是170万，
假如说我1000万，
如果这个占比，
算17%的话，
我整个ICM，
IM,
占比就要到70%左右。
我剩下的权益，
类的还是占了20%，
黄金10%,
白银3%,
但是,
因为它是一个保证金，
它当中还有很大，
你可以挪用的这部分资金吗？
我会再去买Port，
Port和Micro,。
有点类似于一个领口策略。
那肯定还是，
利用你的美股账户，
再做了，是吧？
不是啊，
A股也可以，
A股和美股，
都在用同样的方式来操作。
不一样，
我没有在美股账户，
去Micro,
但是我有买NAS的Port，
作为一些对冲。
这个是什么时候，
开始执行的？
大概今年的，
它因为是一个，
陆陆续续的过程，
甚至到这周，
我也都还在调整。
有看到一些，
阶段性的，
和之前的曲线的不同吗？
我当中还采了别的坑，
所以我今年的收益率，
其实不怎么样。
我今年，
采的坑是黄金期权，
学期权的过程，
当中有一段时间，
我做的是双脉策略。
双脉策略，
你在遇到今年，
黄金的那个走势，
简直像地狱一样的体验，
然后后来就止损了。
所以我今年，
在黄金期权上，
亏了可能，
我2%到3%的一个资产吧。
但是,
我现在的这套体验，
前面三月份暴跌的时候，
我能感觉到，
它的毁撤的控制是不错的。
我比如说，
我的Gone ICIM,。
我亏的钱，
我60%可以通过期权，
再补回来。
这套策略，
如果它是一个组合的话，
你给它设的一个最大毁撤，
大概是一个什么样的水平？
同时,
它的对应的收益率，
又是什么样的水平？
因为我之前，
都是用XL去做一些，
十年的数据的毁测，
到期权期货之后，
超出了我写XL的能力了。
所以我现在没有，
拿这个时机去测过。
如果排除掉期权的这一部分的话，
我之前测的大概整个毁测，
是在30%以内，
收益率大概是在12%.。
资产配置大的规划来说，
这是一个自己想要的一个值吗？
我觉得是可以接受的。
就是增长12%，
但回测30%。
我觉得年化增长12%已经很好了，
因为它的最大毁撤，
不是说它每年会发生，
它可能十年会发生一次。
这套方法论，
会给自己的家人，
比如给你老公讲解一下吗？
我老公，
其实他不太爱投资，
因为他是一个极度分解，
厌恶的人。
投资这个事儿，
我跟他唯一的接触是，
国内不是有那个个人养老金吗？
然后我就让他之前买了一个4F，
表现也不太好。
那每次打开看到那个4F亏了，
他都对，
他是有一定心理压力的。
所以我后来，
我会跟他讲，
比如说我这个月，
我们家整体资产变成这样了，
长了因为什么，
然后回撤了因为什么，
但是就是整个的，
怎么做资产配置的那个逻辑，
我不会跟他讲的太细。
所以这基本就是自己在，
调整和自己在学习的一个过程？
对，然后也有一些朋友吧，
交流投资的朋友，
其实好像还是跟我背景类似的，
就是也是互联网出身，
中年发言，
对对对对，
你觉得你现在满意自己发言之后的生活吗？
我感觉他是每个阶段感受不太一样，
最近还挺好的，
什么时候会感觉不好？
当中有半年，
花了特别多的时间在学心理学，
又有一种很不自由的感觉，
就是虽然学心理学这个事，
是我自己想干的，
然后我当时还报了一个硕士的课程吧，
你要拿到那个硕士的文凭，
他是需要进行考试的，
他叫同等学历深述，
然后我就会觉得我花了太多的时间，
其实在做一些又没有那么想做的事情，
比如说这个考试的背考，
那个时候就感觉挺内耗的。
那学习不都得经历这些吗？
不是啊，
纯学着玩当然可以了，对吧？
对啊，我现在就是纯学着玩。
带考试的咱就算了？
应该是，我好像目前为止，
我不会再想象自己在投入一个需要考试的学习经历当中。
如果你刚才说的就是，
比如说一个每年度的收益率能够到百分之十几，
是一个相对来说你比较理想的一个未来的一个指标，
你觉得你在方法论的迭代上面，
到什么时候会是一个穷劲？
我举个例子，比如说你原来全面做多的一个策略吗？
虽然你咱也做了资产配置，
但它是一个完全做多的策略。
在那样一个市场环境下，
你做了那样的一个策略，
无法达到你的收益率，
所以你才开始去想这种多空的策略，
还是说你就是有对不断迭代策略的这种需求，
来去测试不同的效果。
我现在没有办法就是预计这个事，
因为说实话我每一轮迭代之后，
就都对自己特别满意，
觉得我不会再迭代了，
然后隔半年又会输入到不同的一些理论也好，
然后或者是不同的市场环境也好，
所以想法又会变化。
但这个变化，
也是像早期咱们做互联网产品一样，
你切一部分来做AVTEST，
它是说咱就全仓上，上新的方法。
我不会AVTEST，
但我确实会一点点切，
切的过程中我投资品类的一些感觉，
新的对它的感受是什么样的，
比如说当中做双脉，
然后我又放弃了这个策略，
因为我发现它有它的问题在，
或者说它确实不适合我。
明白，我刚才说的那种，
你切一大块资产来AVTEST，
可能也是另外一种方式，
但是这些方式的背后，
假设你阶段性的看到了，
它们两个数值不一样，
你会担心这里面，
它有阶段性外部市场的因素吗？
它不是你策略导致的，
给你造成误判。
可能有，
那就是你过了这个时间段，
你在反思吗？
你看我虽然比如说，
到现在五年，
我切了四个大的策略，
但是我不太会有回头，
又到了原来那个版本的状态。
那是因为就已经确定，
正是原来那不好了吗？
对，是的，
所以我放弃一个套路，
我是能想清楚，
为什么放弃它？
它当然会有市场的那一部分在，
但是它更多的是，
让我看到我新的这个东西，
它在不同的市场环境下，
它也有它自己的局限，
所以我又找到了新的解法，
但是我能够记得很清楚，
我上回踩的那个坑，
它坑在哪儿，
我不要再掉进去。
明白,
所有的这几轮，
你的迭代，
包括你现有的这个策略，
你给到普通听有一些建议的话，
当然咱们不说就是跨市场的，
你实际的买卖的一些硬性限制条件，
比如你现在可能无法开美股账户了，
恰好你又切到了一种偏指数类的策略，
那我们在国内也是可以实现的，
你觉得你的策略里面，
哪些是值得推广的，
哪些是不太建议的？
我说实话，
我没有想要去推广过的策略的，
就是现阶段我没有这样的想法，
原因在于我自己做这个策略，
也只有半年左右，
我没有那么大的信心，
它一定就是可以借鉴了，
刚刚没有聊到一个点是说，
我为什么做滚IC，
滚IM是因为之前看那个大牛猫的文章，
然后他提到这个东西也很多年了，
我其实知道这个东西可能也有五六年了，
我也是去年刚开始真的上手做这个东西，
我能看到的一个巨大的风险点是，
在下跌的时候毁撤是非常可怕的，
这个是为什么，
我不会裸着去滚IC和IM，
我不想承受那种一天，
比如说回社100万这样的感受，
但是我又觉得，
齐全这个东西，
他的学习是带有一定的成本在的，
因为齐全他的操作的自由性，
又比股票高了好几个维度，
你增加了到期时间，
增加了方向，
增加了你的可以买卖的价格，
整个的复杂性变得很高，
所以我没有很想要，
要安利和推荐大家，
一定要按这个方式做。
对，听起来，
其实就是比普通的买股票，
买一只宽机，肯定是要复杂得多的。
比如说你在这个复杂的这一套方法里面，
你觉得能带给你的是什么呢？
就是说你确实看到了他的对冲效果，
或者他的评议你的波动的能力，
就是显著增强了，
还是说，
比如说，
其实有一个更简单的躺平的方法。
他对比我的上一版策略来说，
一个是他在牛市，
可以吃到大段的收益，
第二个是他不怕大幅回彻，
这个就是他带给我的，
但是他这一套策略，
确实就是我到现在我也不敢说，
我完全跑明白了。
明白。
他比,
就是我上一版就是那个，
你定好一个持仓目标，
定期做在平衡，
这样的策略的复杂度要高很多。
你比如说，
你原来说你在A股里面，
可能你就配忽然三百家，
中正五百是吧？
是的。
当时怎么没想到，
这些更进攻性的行业类的指数？
行业不就是我上一次才的那个坑吗？
就再往前的一次。
对对对，
因为你一旦就是再细分到行业的话，
一个是说你怎么控制整个A股的，
他的持仓占比的问题。
控不住这个东西，
然后你又不做对冲，
因为A股这种，
就是整个阴跌的熊市，
他在历史的占比很高，
你那个体验就会很差，
这个是我不做行业的一个原因，
第二个是说，
真的要理解到单一行业是个复杂度很高的事情，
钱你即使理解到了，
它跟你赚不赚钱也没什么关系，
比如说我对橫科的理解，
肯定超过我对任何别的行业，
因为橫科的核心的公司，
不是我工作过的，
就是我很多朋友在，
对对对，
我也没在上面赚到钱，
就是我有什么自信说，
换一个行业我可以赚到钱。
所以你的方法就是还是去，
规避了，
或者说我已经明确的说，
我已经没有个股的研究能力，
甚至是没有行业的研究能力，
在这样一个大的前提下，
然后我去解释这个问题，
对，是的，
大概的时间段fire的这些朋友们，
尤其是也有投资经历的朋友们，
秉承的方法论是类似的吗，
还是各有各的方法，
有朋友是类似的，
也有的朋友是差异比较大的，
就有些他还是这种个股型的选手，
是的,
你教练比如说收益率是不是显著的比你高，
我自己的伯克第一期聊的那个朋友，
他是过去八年的收益率是，
每股这一部分是20%，
但因为他是一半的资产在美股，
一半在国内配一些阿一阿二的这种，
低风险的投资产品，
所以你整个资产来说的话，
其实可能差不了太多。
完全不羡慕其他的这种高收益？
不能说不羡慕，
但是我很确定自己做不到什么，
比如说刚刚讲到的行业和个股，
那就是我确定我自己搞不了的板块，
我就不会再忘了，
因为我试过了，
我搞过了，
我确定我没有那个能力，
我就不会再去羡慕它。
最终来看就是，
追求每年百分之十几的这样的一个增长，
可能就是之后的一个比较核心的目标了，
是的,
然后通过这样的一些新的策略的迭代，
但是我都是为了完成这个目标的，
是的,
而不是要提高我的收益率，
也提高收益率，
比如说我最大回撤，
在百分之三十以内，
如果我还有能力再提高一些，
我是OK的，
但是如果它是一个大幅会使得我的最大回撤，
不可控的那种方式，
我就不会去考虑。
明白,
现在这种生活方式，
肯定相对来说，
你还是比较满意的，是吧？
目前是满意的，
可能直到出现一个大回撤，
你是不是要重新思考一下，
现在的整个的生活方式？
它分成两种，
一个是股市的大回撤，
那首先要看我的资产配置，
它是不是能扛住这个大回撤，
发现扛不住的情况下，
我首先思考的应该是，
我怎么去调整我的这个策略，
使得它能扛住大回撤？
因为现在其实也就是个。
四十岁左右的年龄，
接下来这样一直下去，
你现在会感受到一些，
未来我可能还会有一些变化吗？
虽然我都在退休的这个状态里，
但我其实在干的，
主要的事情变化还挺多的，
比如说我最近可能投比较多时间的是，
录我自己的播客，
为了录播客和不同的朋友聊天，
更新公众号，
最近准备学个手碟，
每天接小孩，然后陪伴他，
这个时候我现在占我生活比较多时间的，
再往前切半年，
我可能除了就是陪伴小孩之外，
主要的时间都在学心理学。
所以投资即便你现在上了一个。
相对比之前复杂一些的策略，
也并没有耽误你多少时间是吗？
是的，所有的策略的变动，
我有一个前提，
就是这个新的策略，
他不会小我很多时间，
比如说做期权，
他要做alpha平衡，
被他平衡，
每一天去关注那个数据，
我就不会做这种东西，
那你现在也不是每天都要打开你的持仓，
或者打开你的这个，
我每天会看一眼，
但真的就是看一眼，
哎，今天是这样的，
因为大部分时间，
你的涨跌指数可能就是在1%以内，
你的规则里一般什么时间。
会促使你去做一些调整？
新的这套规则其实很少了，
因为它最多的调整是，
我要买port，
过一段时间port的价值就会下来，
因为它的时间价值就会下来，
我可能会再去补一些port，
作为我的对冲，
但如果是遇到暴跌的环境，
目前,
可能还没赶上，
3月份算赶上，
但也不算特别大的暴跌，
我好像也就是看着它，
干不了什么别的，
如果是一个纯错多的策略，
感觉也是这样的，
比如说出现了一个回彻，
也并不会紧急的有什么操作，
可能也就是看着它，
我会补仓啊，
以前因为是一个PE分位的策略，
就是一跌你的PE分位，
就一下子下来了，
我有一个google sheet,。
就是算我现在该持有多少股数，
然后我就看那个差额是多少，
我就重新去买入，
现在反而比可能之前操作更少了，
那挺好的，
符合你说的fire这几个词的一个核心用意，
并不是说所谓退休了之后，
不在职场，
但实际上为了解决你生存危机，
花的时间变得更长了，
不会这样，
最后给到我们的一些偏投资类的庭友，
你的一些整体的感悟吧，
就像你说的可能具体的策略，
没有办法给出一些很明确的一些指引啊，
但就是这个你现在的生活状态，
以及包括资产配置对你的，
这一套生活状态的一个补充的意义，
能不能再跟我们去分享一些。
这种总结性的感受吧？
第一个点就是我要从每一次毁设中成长，
当你亏钱的时候，
就是人肯定是会有很大的焦虑或者不适的，
你要从这种当中获得点什么，
它会使得你的整个策略，
未来是能够对抗至少有相同的环境的，
当然环境会持续的变化，
第二个点是我觉得，
需要有自己的体系和规则在，
比如说你就是爱研究个股，
那当然也是ok的，
但是个股你的持仓的配置是怎么样的，
补仓的节奏是怎么样的，
补完了之后，
它到你的资产上线是怎么样的，
我觉得这个东西其实是挺重要的，
就因为我最早做个股的时候，
我很经常犯的一个错误是，
一跌就买，
举个例子，
可能每团四百六，
可能三百五我就觉得机会来了，
就可能一下子已经补到顶了，
这是一个新手容易犯的错误，
就是缝低加仓，
反而在你看来是一个错误，
缝低加仓的太快，
缝低当然该加仓，
但是你应该是有一个自己加仓的节奏在的，
你刚才提到的就是这个里面，
挺关键的就是，
每次回设能够给你一些，
咱就姑且说教训吧，
或者一些改变，
我相信就是大家在回设的时候，
确实有一部分人他是啥也不干，
那还有一部分就是，
我确实想着我怎么能够迭代，
就怕有说每一次回设，
我都要想重新定义我的这个投资框架，
这是不是又有点这种疾病乱头医的感觉？
对，也会有，
你要去思考，
但未必是说，
你思考的结果就是你现在是错的。
你出现过这种情况吗？
比如说我今年三月的他的回设，
我就没有觉得我是错的，
反而让我觉得是对的，
就是我做对冲的这个体系，
他的思路是对的。
好，最后一个小问题，
如果我们的一些朋友他开始思考，
我是不是要寻求退休，
在做这个重要的人生决定之前，
他首先应该想明白那几件事，
才会可以做出这个决定。
我觉得这个事挺难的，
我只能说我当时自己想明白了那几件事，
第一个是财务上。
还是得算个账吗？
对，我自己会算个账，
但也有朋友是不算账的，
我是一个挺J的人，
所以我是要把账算明白，
就是我们家可能未来花钱的是那几项，
投资受益率可能是什么样的，
不同的环境下我会承担什么样的风险，
我是不是能够挺住，
大致的心理有底之后，
是会让自己更有底气一点，
第一点就是财务上的。
第二个点是，
之前也跟一些就是，
FIRE可能一年，
比如说他有回职场的人，
我跟一个人去聊过，
每个人其实他是有不同的。
成就感的那种来源的，
他的来源是在于，
我组织一群人干成了一件事，
就是如果你的成就感来源是这样的话，
你FIRE之后的体验可能不太好。
还是在组织里没软你的成就感更好？
是的，是的。
你接触的这种咱们答应，
FIRE失败的人多吗？
不多，目前为止就接触了一个。
就是又返回职场的？
是的,
然后这个返回职场完全不是经济原因？
对，FIRE之后，
他觉得他的这种成就感没了。
所以第二个算是建议吧，
就是还是要想清楚你的成就感的来源是什么？
是的。
到底能不能从此走向自己一个人在家的这种生活？
经济上，精神能量上吧，
比较大的来源，
非常好的建议。
之前也采访过一些不同种类的FIRE的人，
当然最终我们的这个伯克肯定还是要走向，
你怎么样通过一个你自己独立的投资能力，
辅佐你的FIRE的这种方法论的。
这样的话，
当然能够支撑你和你的家庭更好的生活，
但同时，
我们也能看到在支撑了这段生活之后，
其他的一些好的这种能量和优势就慢慢的显现出来了。
我们也希望借着和萌萌聊这期节目，
对于那些人道中年，
不管你有没有焦虑，
就是想开始去思考，
你是不是要做这种financial independence？
Retire Early的这个决策的时候，
能够有一些思考和方法论的一些基点。
今天感谢萌萌到我们的现场来做分享。
我们下期节目再见。
拜拜。